Thor Ragnarok just got its first glorious
trailer and it's packed with teases for the
upcoming third Thor movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm breaking down the new
Thor Ragnarok trailer for easter eggs and
other hidden details you might have missed.
So, of course, there's speculation and potential
spoilers ahead for Thor Ragnarok.
Let's start with that awesome shot of Thor
throwing his hammer at Hela.
Notice how this sequence is happening on Earth.
And just there next to Thor in the alley,
it looks like Loki.
This links back to the mid-credits scene of
the Doctor Strange movie where Thor visits
Strange in his Sanctum Sanctorum and explains
that he needs to bring Loki to New York to
look for their father Odin who's gone missing.
Now, back to this trailer, Hela, of course,
destroys Thor's hammer, crushing it into small
pieces.
It's interesting that Thor's hammer gets destroyed
because we're still waiting to find out where
the final Infinity Stone, the Soul stone,
is hidden, and one theory is that it could
be hidden inside Thor's hammer.
Is it possible Hela did this to get to the
missing stone?
An alternate Soul stone theory states that
it's contained in Heimdall's armour and, if
you notice in this scene from the trailer,
he's not wearing his usual armour, so I also
wonder whether this has anything to do with
the Soul stone?
OK, back to Hela, and this awesome shot of
her with her full headgear looks stunningly
like it's taken right from the comic books.
And her antler-like gear also appears in another
shot later where she's battling the war goddesses
known as the Valkyrior who are mounted on
their winged horses in what could be a flashback
scene.
Notice the blue cape which Valkyrie often
has in the comics and, as the Valkyrior attack
Hela, the Goddess of Death launches her sword
and the next shot is of Valkyrie, falling
together with other defeated warriors in the
distance.
Valkyrie's defeat presumably is the reason
why we find her working for the Grandmaster
later in the trailer rather than living on
Asgard.
By the way, like the Collector from Guardians
of the Galaxy, the Grandmaster is one of the
Elders of the Universe, and they both have
a similar look including markings on their
lip and chin.
And given it's the game-loving Grandmaster
who's presiding over the gladiator battles
in the movie, it looks like he's taking on
a similar role in this story to the Red King,
who ruled the planet Sakaar in the Planet
Hulk storyline in the comics, which I'll talk
more about shortly.
Curiously, in the comics, at one time, the
Grandmaster had the Mind Gem.
Now, in the MCU, that's actually possessed
by Vision.
So, it's also possible that, in the movie,
the Grandmaster might be the one with the
final Infinity Stone, aka the Soul Stone.
Back on Asgard, we see a sweeping view of
the city complete with the Rainbow bridge,
aka the Bifrost, which allows travel between
the Nine Realms.
And Hela is there in front of an army of Asgardian
Warriors, without her head-dress, and pulls
out her sword uttering the words "Asgard is
dead" just before a huge explosion sweeps
through the city, which, interestingly, passes
over a very particular tree.
This tree looks like a representation of the
symbolic Yggdrasil tree, which has already
appeared in two previous Marvel movies.
The first time it appeared was in the first
Captain America movie where it was carved
into the wall where Red Skull discovered the
Tesseract.
Its second appearance was when Thor sketched
the tree as a way to explain the Nine Realms
to Jane Foster.
The Yggdrasil tree in both the movies and
the comics connects all the nine realms and
the destruction of the tree by Hela symbolises
the extent of the devastation she's unleashed
on Asgard.
By the way, the word "Ragnarok" means the
series of events in Norse mythology that foretell
"the Doom of the Gods".
So now we've introduced the main villain Hela,
let's step back to the beginning of the trailer
where Thor is being dropped into a huge fiery
cavern.
As Thor dangles there, notice these faces
lighting up with one of them also opening
its mouth slightly.
These could be either fire demons, which in
the comics originate from the realm of Muspelheim,
where the enormous and hugely powerful demon
Surtur rules.
Alternately, the faces could be souls of the
dead in Hela's domain Hel.
The faces appear to be kind of stacked in
mounds, one on top of the other, which seems
to indicate these could be tormented souls
that Hela has acquired.
However, footage shown at San Diego Comic
Con revealed a scene of the Hulk getting ready
to fight Surtur, meaning the Hulk might be
about to burst in and save Thor here.
Either way, I can't wait to find out.
The other location we get a really good look
at is the planet Sakaar.
If you look up at the sky, you can see all
these portals which are basically wormholes
that connect to various parts of the universe
which is how Thor got there.
And the portals are also a way for the rest
of the universe to dump their trash on Sakaar.
In the comics, Sakaar is the location where
the Planet Hulk storyline takes place and
it's inhabited by all kinds of dodgy characters
which we get to see in the trailer.
So, we know that some elements of Planet Hulk
are being used in the movie such as Hulk having
to fight as a gladiator on Sakaar.
In the comics, he ends up there after he's
sent into space for being too dangerous; however,
quite why and how he ended up there in the
MCU isn't clear just yet.
In Ragnarok, we're going to see Thor have
to fight without his mighty hammer.
And last time Thor had to face Hulk without
his hammer in the first Avengers movie, things
didn't exactly go brilliantly for Thor!
Not only has he been painted here, but he's
also had his hair cut short for the arena.
This short-haired look tips its hat to The
Unworthy Thor comics where the God of Thunder
also deals with the consequences of losing
the ability to wield his hammer.
But at least Thor has got himself a cool-looking
new helmet.
And the last time we saw him with a helmet
was in the first Thor movie.
Thor's replacement weapon which is a kind
of club could be a nod to the Golden Mace
weapon wielded by Hercules in the comics.
I thought the Hulk's gladiator look was just
fantastic including much of his Planet Hulk
look from the comics.
There's also a great nod to "The Incredible
Hulk" comic book, TV and movie titles when
he's introduced as the "incredible" just before
he Hulk smashes his way into the arena.
That line that Thor says about Hulk being
a friend from work was just brilliant too,
and reminded me that even when the two have
worked together, for example during the battle
of New York in the Avengers movie, that didn't
stop the Hulk giving Thor one of his trademark
side-punches!
But the tone of this scene also made me think
of those hilarious Thor mockumentaries where
Thor's friend Darryl tells the Asgardian god
that he should get a job, to which Thor replies
that he already has a one, saving the planet.
In fact, although Thor Ragnarok isn't a full-on
comedy, director Taika Waititi has said he
wanted to make use of Chris Hemsworth and
Mark Ruffalo's comedic chops in what becomes
a kind of road movie.
And in the gladiator arena, we see the Grandmaster's
booth which includes some very interesting
characters, including what could be a Celestial,
plus Loki is there too.
Celestials have already shown up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in Guardians of the Galaxy.
Eson The Searcher was a celestial who destroyed
a planet with the Power Stone, and the mining
colony Knowhere was, as Gamora explained in
that movie, "the severed head of an ancient
celestial being".
Ragnarok director Taika Waititi also teased
another Celestial helmet on his Instagram
and there's been speculation this helmet belongs
to the Celestial Ziran the Tester.
Ziran the Tester is part of the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline in the comics, so Thor Ragnarok
may be about to give the Celestials a more
important role in the MCU going forward.
By the way, it looks like there's a cameo
here also by actress Rachel House who was
in director Taika Waititi's previous movie,
Hunt for the Wilderpeople.
You might also have heard her recently as
the voice of Gramma Tala in Disney's Moana.
And Taika Waititi also snuck in a Hunt for
the Wilderpeople easter egg via this graffiti
behind Thor which reads Skux Life.
"Skux Life" is a slang phrase protagonist
Ricky Baker uses to talk about being gangsta
and the phrase has a similar meaning to "Thug
Life".
And director Waititi has also talked about
how influential the work of the legendary
comic book artist and writer Jack Kirby has
been on the look of Ragnarok, and we can see
various visual homages to Kirby in the trailer.
For example, the wall behind the Grandmaster
is literally taken straight from the design
on a power core in "The Sentry Sinister" Fantastic
Four comic.
The trailer also introduces us to this guy:
Skurge, aka the Executioner, who's played
by Karl Urban, and the scene looks like it's
been taken straight from Thor issue 362 in
which Skurge makes a noble sacrifice by defending
the bridge out of Hel, protecting Thor and
a group who are trying to get out of there.
Thor's vision in Avengers: Age of Ultron had
Heimdall accusing Thor, saying to him, "They
see you leading us to Hel".
So could Thor: Ragnarok involve Thor having
to get the Asgardians out of Hel and might
Skurge sacrifice himself in a similar way
to the comics?
Now, it's unclear whether this scene involving
Loki has anything to do with the bridge out
of Hel that Skurge is defending.
Behind Loki is a mass of people who look to
be trying to break through, while Loki does
a cool-looking double-dagger flip.
By the way, in the comics, Goddess of Death,
Hela, is actually Loki's daughter, so it'll
be interesting to see if there's any relation
between them in the movie.
And this is an interesting scene with a spacecraft
positioning itself to shoot through that portal,
which is curiously shaped and coloured like
an eye.
Perhaps it's Thor, Hulk and Valkyrie leaving
Sakaar.
But what is intriguing is that the colours
of the craft are the same as the colours of
Captain Marvel's costume, and, of course,
one of Captain Marvel's skills is her expertise
as a pilot.
It might not be Marvel herself, but could
this be an awesome little tease for her movie?
Music-wise, the trailer features the awesome
Led Zeppelin track "Immigrant Song", the lyrics
for which, appropriately enough, include the
words "hammer of the gods" and references
to Norse mythology.
So, guys, what did you think of the Thor:
Ragnarok trailer?
Were there any other details you spotted?
And do you think we'll get an infinity stone
reveal in the movie?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate your
likes and shares, and while you're here check
out some of my other trailer breakdowns and
Marvel videos by tapping or clicking here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!